now I'm kind of amazed at this film dump
made and I'm wondering were you amazed
at the time it got made and are you
stole yeah I mean I guess I'm amazed I I
think having made Milano che and and
during the period of between Milano che
and Drugstore Cowboy was a period where
I had written many different screenplays
and three of them were sort of
concerning this storyline one was a
short story sort of like a a map with
which to make a film which was called My
Own Private Idaho and there was another
one which was men called minions of the
moon which was emulating Orson Welles as
chimes at midnight on the streets of
Oregon like an update updating of his of
his selections of Shakespeare and
Falstaff the character of Falstaff
Shakespearean character and then there
was a third screenplay for the the
minions of the Moon was a full
screenplay that I used to shop around
here with an agent and then the third
was called in a blue funk which was
about Mike and a German auto parts
salesman called Hans who was who was in
my head sort of a rain or fassbender
character with the moustache and glasses
until I met when I went to with with
Milano jet to the Berlin Film Festival I
ran into Tokyo and I thought I had seen
him in Andy Warhol's Frankenstein and
Andy Warhol's Dracula and I thought
maybe you know he'd be interested so and
he was so um I was fortunate to get him
and and I didn't really encourage him to
dress up like Rainer Werner Fassbinder
but um but so but you you initially had
tried to get this made but I mean drugs
yeah I guess I guess the part where like
we were trying to get it made was after
we made Drugstore Cowboy and while we
were in say the Toronto Film Festival
with the film it was kind of it was kind
of getting a good response the release
wasn't so it wasn't as like sort of
splashy as I think Sex Lies and
videotape which came out in a similar
year
it didn't go to can for instance we
tried to get into can with Drugstore
Cowboy and I I think I had the this sort
of moment in my life where I could have
you know gone on to do something that
was say something that was more along
the lines of a studio film and they're
worth offers from studios and in
particular some action movies which I
was considering and um and then I had
this screenplay which during the editing
of Drugstore Cowboy I had distilled the
three screenplays down into like a
seventy page piece written on a Mac
which was a kind of a new machine and I
used all the different typefaces that
Steve Jobs carefully designed and known
and so some of the type was really big
and some was tiny and and so when I gave
it to people from Universal they were 70
pages strange type and the story and you
know everything mashing together they
they appreciated Drugstore Cowboy but
they thought maybe the next project
after my own private I mean
after my own private I know they would
jump in and nobody really wanted it they
were like are you sure you don't want to
do this action film yeah and they would
say that and um and then we were trying
to just check with Keanu and River to
see if they might be interested and
figuring that they would just say no
Keanu and his manager you know they
really were interested because Keanu had
done a low-budget film in Portland
already and he you know he had been
doing bigger projects so I think that
was something that he was interested in
River on the other hand had never done
anything like that and he kind of didn't
even know what we were up to like what
sort of a film it was and he we got him
the screenplay his agent just said over
my dead body you're not good
you know and we somehow we got it to him
through some mutual friends just the
actual physical screenplay and I think
he might have heard about it through
Keano as well and they both were calling
and sort of teaming up like you know if
if I do it Keano has to do it I kind of
making the deal themselves they were
actually negotiating with the agent was
out of the picture and and eventually
they were doing it which was very
strange because we had two unknown
characters that we were intending to use
yeah which sort of changed the profile
of the film and and some of those the
original sort of non perfectors that you
had in mind were yes some of those guys
are in like who plays Gary and the guy
who plays digger we're actually going to
be Mike and Scott Mike Parker being
being Mike waters was the real Bob gonna
be Bob yeah I think maybe the real Bob
was gonna be our friend Bob who plays
the first John in the in the film and I
guess he would he would have had to do
Shakespeare which would have been
difficult because he had emphysema
but um yeah it was it was sort of like
this very very strange small project
that I just insisted on doing promised
myself that I would do and I would keep
pushing it and it's just somehow
probably through Drugstore Cowboy got
going but this initially was maybe gonna
be another mala noche and in the sense
of Independence was Drugstore Cowboy was
supposed to be you know like a hundred
thousand dollar movie in black and white
John in Portland but it became a four
million dollar movie and this one was
also supposed to be like you know
however however much money just small
amount kind of homemade but it also sort
of blew up into a bigger project